le rio grande baie un long fleuve
tranquille
meetic qui coule entre deux amériques
obstacle sur la route des migrants
c'est donc le théâtre d'un jeu de piste
s et 100 pour les gardes frontières
américains
constamment aux aguets à la recherche
des 10 de passage ici draw rosales est
un policier du comté d'hidalgo où tu
exerces appelés en renfort pour
patrouiller les berges du rio grande et
de toute sa carrière il n'a jamais vu un
tel afflux de migrants
les gardes frontière sont débordés dit
il alors on est là pour les aider
la recherche ne dure pas longtemps sur
la berd
à peine débarqué déjà un premier groupe
les femmes des enfants comme elisabeth
venus du honduras avec ses deux filles
anna et fernande soulagés d'être arrivés
elle remercie dieu d'être encore en vie
nous avons beaucoup souffert dit elle
nous avons failli mourir en route
c'était très dangereux beaucoup de
migrants
elle a entendu parler du nouveau
président joe biden et de son attitude
plus conciliante
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y avait de
nouvelles lois dit elle et qu'il allait
réunir les familles changement de
politique directement responsable de
l'afflux aux frontières selon ce
policier
des centaines arrivent chaque jour
la crise la plus grave depuis 20 ans au
milieu de la foule le policier joël
contreiras remarque une fillette seule
elle s'appelle yale et gna elle vient du
guatemala et n'a que 8 ans situation
malheureusement loin d'être isolé car
les enfants non accompagnés ne sont pas
refouler beaucoup de parents choisissent
donc d'envoyer leurs enfants seuls kamal
une tendance qui inquiète les autorités
une décision incompréhensible pour ce
policier
c'est extrêmement dangereux pour un
enfant dit il avec tout ce qui peut
arriver
ces gens viennent tous d'amérique
centrale ils ont donc parcouru des
milliers de kilomètres mais leur périple
est loin d'être terminée assoiffé
exténué ils doivent encore parcourir des
kilomètres à pied pour arriver jusqu'aux
gardes frontières et agents
d'immigration chargés de les enregistrer
et puis viendra la tante interminables
dans des centres d'accueil surpeuplée
pour que soit étudié leur dossier s'ils
sont parvenus à mettre le pied dans ce
pays dont ils ont tant rêver le plus dur
ils le savent sera de réussir à y rester
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada
mais sean au texas